and we're going to continue to cover
this until the threat is over until the
situation is dealt with which will
likely be many more months so why is
CNN's brian Stelter saying it quote
faded from the news and that Obama
predicted it would happen here now
conservative commentator and author of
the book resistance is futile and
Coulter in Univision anchor and recast
Vito who is on the border in Tijuana
tonight and wreak a I want to start with
you because you heard William laun
janessa's report he's been with the
caravan for weeks covering it especially
in Tijuana the people of Tijuana don't
want this we have reports that children
and women have disappeared from the one
of the caravans perhaps kidnapped by
human traffickers that news from a USA
Today piece from yesterday what are your
what are your thoughts here I mean this
seems very very concerning well first of
all to answer your question Laura the
part of the community part of local
residents here in Tijuana have
criticized the presence of the migrant
caravan but the overwhelming majority
have shown a compassionate and
humanitarian reaction of haha
due to their presence so it's not all of
the Iguana some people in Tijuana don't
want them here but I would say the
majority have shown this compassion and
an empathy on the other hand about the
disappearance the alleged disappearance
of a large group of migrants that were
part of the caravan it just goes to show
you the difficult conditions the
incredible violence that they face in
their journey through Mexico towards the
US border so the caravan is not just one
thing it has many realities it has
thousands of different stories so it's
not very helpful to frame the debate in
absolutes I think there's context and
there's nuance and we should President
Obama said back in 2014
do not bring your children the the trek
is dangerous do not bring them he said
because you will not be allowed to stay
of course most of them were allowed to
stay and torture an Coulter you remember
that I mean this was out these these are
now
hundred children and women who are gone
and this is a report from our open but
ombudsman for human rights in Wakulla
told the HuffPo mexico he is it on very
good authority very very good reporting
so this this magnet in the united states
of previously at least catch and release
Pueblo steam for Dante Otis organizing
this they are putting people's lives in
danger are they not yes yes they are and
President Trump has already signed an
executive order on human trafficking
this was obviously a campaign stunt they
hoped the caravan would arrive on
America's border just before the midterm
elections to show that not only do we
not have a wall but Trump can't stop
them here you have this huge invasion
coming in they could show the women
separated from their children again they
planned this as a campaign stunt but
then Trump took them up on it called
their bluff said he's sending troops to
the border and suddenly Obama is talking
about it being what did he call it a
myth of the caravan well it's still
coming and and the people who did
arrange this country's Without Borders
in in Spanish I mean they are they are
setting up these women and children to
be raped murdered sold to other people
as you say from all this reporting we're
getting now they ought to be prosecuted
for inciting for encouraging human
smuggling we have laws on the books
about this they set this in motion look
I don't want all of Latin America moving
to America due to our country but I
don't want them being murdered and raped
along the way leftist don't care they
don't care they wanted a political stunt
and women and children are being killed
because of it
alright guys thanks so much